BUT WE'LL GO AND GET STARTED.
MEMBERS OF THE OMMITTEE
WELCOME TO THIS AFTERNOON'S
HEARING ON EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE. TODAY WE HAVE
SEVENTEEN BILL TO CONSIDER AND
THIRTEEN OF THOSE WILL BE HEARD
ON CONSENT. AS YOU KNOW DUE TO
COVER NINETEEN WE HAVE LIMITED
ROOM. AVAILABLE FOR THE PUBLIC
IN IN THIS ROOM AND IN ROOM ONE
TWENTY SIX OF THE CAPITAL WHICH
IS THE WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCE
ROOM FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF THE MASS
REQUIREMENTS FOR EVERYONE. IN
THE ROOM AND IN ROOM TWENTY SIX
AND MAINTAIN PHYSICAL
DISTANCING. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC PUBLIC CAN PARTICIPATE
IN TODAY'S TERM BY CALLING. ONE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE PIN
NUMBER IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN. OR BY
VISITING THE COMPANY'S WEBSITE
AT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV.
EVERY PERSON WITH THE WITNESS
IN THE PUBLIC COMMENT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS
THAT THE SOMEBODY HAS RULES TO
ENSURE WE MAINTAIN ORDER. AND
RUN AN EFFICIENT HEARING. WE
SEEK TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
ALL WHO PARTICIPATE IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. SO WITH
THAT WE HAVE EFFECTIVE
DELIBERATION AND DECISIONS ON
CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THESE BECAUSE WE
WERE NOT PERMIT CONDUCT THE
DISTRUST DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE.
IMPEDE THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS. IN
ADDITION THIS YEAR. WILL AGAIN
BE COMPLAIN ABOUT WITH ALL
PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS. ARISING
OF A COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
SCENE WE HAVE A QUORUM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HERE OKAY.
THERE YOUR- CALDERON. GALLAGHER
OKAY RIGHT- WARS RIGHT BEFORE.
OKAY WHAT THE HEAVENS W.
CORPSMAN FOR THE MATURE
BUSINESS WHICH IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE FOLLOWING ITEMS
ARE ON CONSENT. AB FOUR FIFTY
GONZALEZ A. B. FIVE THIRTY SIX
RODRIGUEZ AB FIVE EIGHTY
RODRIGUEZ AB SIX NINETEEN
CALDERON. AB TEN SIXTY
RODRIGUEZ AB TWELVE OH TWO
CERVANTES AB TWELVE SEVENTEEN
RODRIGUEZ AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FIVE WORKS. AB FOURTEEN OH NINE
LEVINE A. B. FOURTEEN FORTY ONE
CERVANTES A. B. FOURTEEN FORTY
EIGHT TORONTO AS AN A. B.
FIFTEEN SIXTY SEVEN COMMITTEE
AND A. B. FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
COMMITTEE. IS THERE A MOTION
OUR SECOND. THERE'S A MOTION
AND A SECOND LARGEST SEGMENT
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HI
RIGHT. I DON'T. CALDERON
GALLAGHER DOLLARS. ONE OKAY
WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
MISSING MEMBERS. FOR THAT WILL
GO ON TO A FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
A. B. ELEVEN OH THREE. NOW YOU
CAN COME FORWARD. YEAH. WELCOME
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AND READING FOR
PROCEED. CARE GOOD AFTERNOON AB
ELEVEN OH THREE CREATES A
STANDARDIZED TRAINING FRAMEWORK
FOR AN AGRICULTURAL PASS
PROGRAM ALLOWING FARMERS AND
RANCHERS TO ACCESS THE PROPERTY
NUMBER DON'T SEE TO SAVE THEIR
LIVESTOCK AND LANDS WHEN
WILDFIRES THREATEN COMMERCIAL
FARMING AND RANCHING OPERATIONS
ROAD CLOSURES OFTEN PREVENT
RANCHERS FROM DOCTRINE OR
ANIMALS PROVIDING WITH THEM
ESSENTIAL WATER AND FEED OR
EVACUATING THEM WALMART DOES HE
RESPOND AS A VOLUNTEER GROUPS
CAN ASSIST IN RESCUING
HOUSEHOLD PETS AND A FEW LARGE
ANIMALS FEEL THAT THE RANGERS
EXPERTISE NECESSARY TO HANDLE
LARGE NUMBERS OF CATTLE OR
OTHER LIVESTOCK. TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE AND HELP RURAL
COMMUNITIES PREPARE FOR
WILDFIRES COUNTY SUCH AS
VENTURA AND SANTA BARBARA HAVE
BEGAN DEVELOPING AN AG PASS
PROGRAM WHICH TRAINS FARMERS OR
RANCHERS AN EMERGENCY RESPONSE
AND IDENTIFY THOSE TRAINED
AGRICULTURISTS TO HIM TO
EMERGENCY PERSONNEL THE AG HAS
PROGRAM ENABLES EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS TO PROVIDE RANCHERS
ACCESS THE PROPERTY TWO TREE
AND RESCUE ANIMALS AND
FACILITATES RANCHERS PROVIDING
SUPPORT TO EMERGENCY PERSONNEL
SUCH AS IDENTIFYING ACCESS
ROADS AND WATER SOURCES. AG
PASSED PROGRAMS ARE NOT
WIDESPREAD IN CALIFORNIA IN
PART BECAUSE OF THE SIGNIFICANT
EFFORT REQUIRED FOR COUNTY TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM WITH NO
STANDARDIZED PROGRAMMER
TRAINING COUNTIES MUST DEVELOP
THEM ON AN INDIVIDUAL BASIS
WHICH IS TIME CONSUMING AND
COSTLY AB ELEVEN OH THREE AS A
SOLUTION AND WILL REQUIRE THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO ESTABLISH
A STATEWIDE FRAMEWORK AND
TRAINING FOR AN ACT PASSED
PROGRAM COVERING FIRE BEHAVIOR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRES A BIRDS ARE
RESPONSE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO AG PASS
HOLDER EXCEPT IN CERTAIN
SPECIFIED CIRCUMSTANCES. WE ARE
WORKING ON LANGUAGE THAT
CLARIFIES LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL
HAVE THE ULTIMATE SAY ON
WHETHER TO STAY FOR AN AG PASS
HOLDER TO ENTER. A DESIGNATED
AREA. I AM CURRENTLY. WITH
STAKEHOLDERS REGARDING
AMENDMENTS. THAT ARE SUMMARIZED
IN THE ANALYSIS WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING TO REAP
ANY CONCERNS ON THE BILL. I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE ON A. B.
ELEVEN OH THREE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
TODAY IS MATHIS OF HERO. FIVE
SECOND RANGE ADVISER TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION IN
VENTURA COUNTY. OKAY WILL HE BE.
THANK A LOT. WHERE YOUR WITNESS
RECENT COMMENTS ON OR OFF ON
THE PHONE OPERATOR TO HAVE
SOMEBODY COME IN SUPPORT. THIS
IS MATTHEW SHAPIRO I'M HERE
YEAH. OKAY GO AHEAD YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT. IF YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY WITH
YOU ALL MY NAME IS MATTHEW
SHAPIRO AND I SERVICE THE
LIVESTOCK AND RANGE ADVISER FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION VENTURA
AND SANTA BARBARA COUNTIES. MY
COMMENT TODAY HOWEVER ARE MINE
ALONE AND DO NOT REFLECT THE
OFFICIAL POSITION OF THE
UNIVERSITY. MY TENURE WITH
EXTENSION HAS BEEN DEFINED BY
WILDFIRE AS JUST MONTHS AFTER I
STARTED MY JOB THE THOMAS FIRE
BURNED THROUGH NEARLY THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES OF
RANGELAND IT MIGHT TO COUNTIES-
DURING THE THOMAS FIRE THAT I
FIRST BECAME AWARE OF THE
VENTURA COUNTY ACT PASSED
PROGRAM. HI COMMITTEE COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
INVENTOR OF SIT IN AND ABOUT
THE WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE.
WITH UNIQUELY IMPACTED BY
WILDFIRE. BROWN ESSENTIALLY AT
THE LOCAL AD HOC PROGRAM THE
ACT PASSED INVENTOR HAS LONG
RELIED ON PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. FIRE AGENCIES IN
THE AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY. IN
THE WAKE OF THE THOMAS FIRE MY
COLLEAGUE MAX MORE THAN I
PREDICT THE PUBLICATION THAT
LEAN DOWN VENTURA COUNTY
EXPERIENCES WITH THE ACT
PASSED. AND PROVIDED A POOP
BLUEPRINT FOR HOW OTHER
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE MIGHT
ESTABLISH A SIMILAR PROGRAM.
THE RESPONSE HAS BEEN JUST
TREMENDOUS. IN MANY COUNTIES
ARE EXPECTING STRONG INTEREST-TO ADOPT THE ACT PASSED
CONCEPT. IN OUR SUMMARY DR
MARTIN I EMPATHIZE THAT GIVEN
THE UNIQUEGEOGRAPHIC AND
ADMINISTRATIVE CONSTRAINTS EACH
COUNTY. THAT THE ACT IN THE
BEST SUITED FOR LOCAL
IMPLEMENTATION. WITH THAT SAID
HOWEVER WE UNDERSTOOD THAT
HAVING A GUIDING STATEWIDE
FRAMEWORK WOULD HAVE CRITICAL
AND MEANINGFUL ADVANTAGES TO
ENSURING. THE SAFETY CONSISTENT
IMPAIR PROGRAM COULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO ALL AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCERS IN CALIFORNIA. I'M
HAPPY TO PROVIDE FURTHER
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE BASED ON
MY EXPERIENCE OF THE LIVESTOCK
AND RANGE ADVISER. AND ANSWER
ANY. OTHER QUESTION SHOULD
THERE BE ANY THANK YOU. THANK
WITH THAT IS THERE ANYBODY. IN
SUPPORT. IN THE ROOM. OPERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. FILET
MIGNON AND THE PHONE LINES IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT. AND AT THIS
TIME IT LOOKS LIKE WE'VE GOT
THREE IN THE QUEUE. WE'LL START
WITH NUMBER SIXTEEN OF SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO TURN
NUMBER IS PRIME SHOW BUT THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGRICULTURE NETWORK FOR CAL
CAN'T. WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY OF WORKING WITH US
ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL. ARE THE
MINIMUM PROPOSED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCED THAT WOULD
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS ABOUT
EMPLOYEE AND FARMWORKERS SAFETY
SO I WANT TO CLARIFY THAT ONCE
THAT THEY'RE OFFICIALLY TAKEN
WE WILL SHIFT OUR POSITION TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. NEXT IS GOING
TO BE NUMBER SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. H. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE NO WAY
OUT KRAMER'S WITH THE WINE
INSTITUTE HERE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU HAVE MEANT
NEXT WILL MOVE TO. YES NEXT
WOULD BE NUMBER THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIRED
MEMBERS MIGHT AND COOK OVER
CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION TO SPONSOR OF AB
ELEVEN I'M PRETTY AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND ONCE
INSURANCE SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS.
ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE MR. THANK YOU
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS MEASURE HERE IN THE
ROOM. OR VIA PHONE OR VIDEO.
OPERATOR DO YOU HAVE ANYBODY ON
THE LINE FOR OPPOSITION. AND
THOSE GERMAN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE NOW PRESS ONE
ZERO AGAIN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE
IN THE QUEUE. HENDO WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF FOURTEEN. A LINE
FOURTEEN YOU ARE OPEN- GOOD
AFTERNOON ARM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS AN
ACCOUNTANT FROM CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION AND WE APPRECIATE-
THAT THAT DID AB ELEVEN OH
THREE IS BEING AMENDED TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS AND IF THE
AMENDMENTS- THAT ARE DETAILED
IN THE ANALYSIS. ARE ADOPTED WE
WILL NO LONGER BE OPPOSED THANK
YOU. MOVED IN ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO FOR THE BILL. AT
THE TIME THERE'S NO FURTHER IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MR.
THANK YOU OPERATOR WITH THAT-
ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEN I THINK THERE IS A MOTION
AND SECOND. WHAT THAT WITH THAT
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER THANK
YOU FOR GOING TO TAKE THE
THREE- COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS RAISED
REGARDING EMPLOYEE SAFETY LOOK
FOR TO SUPPORT HIS BILL TODAY.
AND WITH THAT BRING BACK TO THE
MEMBERS ANY COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS ABOUT NUMBERS. THE
SUMMER GALLAGHER RIGHT YEAH THE
BILL- NEARLY RAN INTO THIS
ISSUE- BOTH IN THE AFTERMATH OF
THE CAMPFIRE AND THE BEAR FIRE
WHERE- YOU KNOW FARMERS- WE'RE
TRYING TO GET BACK TO THEIR
PROPERTIES TO TAKE CARE OF
LIVESTOCK AND ANIMALS AND MORE
OF AND WERE UNABLE TO DO SO I
THINK THIS IS A VERY NECESSARY
CHANGE IN. THE SUPPORTING THE
BILL. THANK YOU OF SIMPLER LIKE
TO CLOSE. TECLAST PRIVATE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT THE OTHERS A
MOTION AND I DO HAVE I RECKON
THAT SO SECRETARY LIKED OF. TO
THE ROLE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO. HI RODRIGUEZ I
STACKED UP HI UP I AGREE. AYE
GREGORY AYE CALDERON ACT
CALDERON I GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER
I'D GREAT. GREAT ABSENT TOWARD.
FORD HI THERE SIX BUTTONS THE
MOTION THAT WILL KEEP THE
RECORD OPEN FOR MISSING MEMBERS.
THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE HAVE A.
B. FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE SUMMER COOLEY.
WHEN YOU'RE READY SIR GOOD. FOR
CALLING FROM TIER THANK YOU FOR.
WE HERE ARE AND- AS I START I
WANT TO COMMEND MICHAEL DAYTON
FOR HIS ANALYTIC WORK ON BEHALF
OF THIS COMMITTEE THIS NEWLY
LAUNCHED COMMITTEE SEVERAL
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT I
RECOGNIZE QUALITY WHEN I SEE
IT- SO I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FARM COLLEAGUES I'M
BRINGING AB FOURTEEN FORTY
SEVENTY YOU AND IT'S ABOUT
CALIFORNIA RURAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. REALLY I'M SORT
OF MOTIVATED BY THOSE FAMILIAR
PHRASES THAT WE'VE HEARD SO
LONG OF THE PEOPLE BY THE
PEOPLE FOR THE PEOPLE. THE BILL
IS KIND OF AN OUTGROWTH OF JUST
RECOGNIZING THE STATE OF
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY IN THE
CHARACTER OF TRYING TO PULL OUR
PEOPLE TOGETHER IN A COMMON
FRAMEWORK OF GOVERNANCE I THINK
THAT IS. A VERY COMPELLING
ISSUE PATIENT ANY DEMOCRACY
AROUND THE GLOBE IN OUR ERA AND
I THINK THE EVENTS OF LAST YEAR
FOR DRIVEN AT. HOME EVEN MORE
POWERFULLY. AND TO TELL YOU A
STORY IN MY EIGHTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT I HAVE THE LITTLE
COMMUNITY OF PERIL. WHICH IS A
FARMING COMMUNITY IN THE
EXTREME SOUTHERN REACHES OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. IT IS AN
EXCEPTIONAL COMMUNITY THE
COMMUNITY LIFE AND HERALD IS
JUST FANTASTIC. THE THINGS THEY
DO TO SUPPORT ONE ANOTHER
SUPPORT GOOD CAUSES TO KIND OF
MAINTAIN THEIR COMMITTEE LIFE
IS JUST SENSATIONAL. R. BUT FOR
COVERT I WOULD HAVE BEEN A DOWN
THERE AT SIX AM ON CHRISTMAS
EVE HAVING A COMMUNITY
BREAKFAST. WHICH THEY JUST SET
UP OUT IN THE COLD IN THE
MORNING IT'S JUST A GREAT
TRADITION. OF BUT WHEN I. WAS
ELECTED TO REPRESENT HERALD. I
WENT TO ADVANCE AT THE OLD BARN.
BY THE OUR FIRE HOUSE WHICH IS
THE INDEPENDENT FIRE DIFFERENT
BONTA FIRE DEPARTMENT. WHICH
WAS THEIR ONE SITE THE TICKET
EVERYONE INSIDE OUT OF THE COLD
AND CONVENER OKAY COMMITTEE
EVENT. AND IT HAS SINCE FALLEN
INTO DISREPAIR AND ACTUALLY
BEEN FIRE MARSHALS LOOK AT
JUDGES NOT SAFE. COULD HOLD
EVENTS. THIS SET ME TO THINKING
ABOUT. THE GREATNESS OF OUR
STATE AND OUR FIFTY COUNTY
SENATE AREAS THAT HAVE ARE NOT
ACTIVELY GROWING SO THEY DON'T
HAVE A ROBUST STREAM OF
REVENUES. AND THE SORTS OF
THINGS THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO
SUSTAIN COMMUNITY HEALTH AND
LIFE. AND WITH THAT WEARING
SINCE I SERVE ON THE SEISMIC
SAFETY COMMISSION. YOU KNOW IT
IS IN THE PARLANCE OF
DISASTROUS BUT YOU'RE HERE AND
REFERENCE IN SOME OF THE
LITERATURE. TO THE NEED TO HAVE
LILY PADS. WHICH ARE VIEWED AS
SMALL AREAS. IN A SPOT WHERE
THERE IS A HAS A REPUBLICAN
CONVENE IN THE EVENT OF A
DISASTER OF MY OLDEST SON IS A
PASTOR OF A CHRISTIAN
MISSIONARY ALLIANCE
CONGREGATION AND IN PARADISE IT
WAS A CHRISTIAN MISSIONARY
ALLIANCE CHURCH THEY HAVE A
LARGE FACILITY IN THE MIDDLE OF
A HUGE PARKING LOT. THE
PROVIDED A VERY IMPORTANT
STAGING AREA AS THE FIRE
UNFOLDED IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. AND SO THAT'S ALL SET
ME TO THINKING AND THAT IS WHAT
BRINGS THIS BILL TO YOU. HOW DO
WE IN THIS TREMENDOUS STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE FUNCTION AS ONE STATE.
SUPPORTING THE BILL OF ALL OUR
COMMUNITIES TO WATCH OVER THEIR
WELL BEING. TO ENJOY THE
COMMUNITY LIFE. AND EVERY SAVE
FOR THE FUTURE. MOST RECENT
DATA FROM THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCES DEMOGRAPHIC JUNE SHOWS
THAT IN TWENTY NINETEEN. TWENTY
EIGHT OF OUR FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES HAD EITHER NO
POPULATION GROWTH. RUSSIA HAD
POPULATION LOSS TWENTY EIGHT OF
FIFTY EIGHT. ARM WHETHER FROM
LACK OF ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY OR
MOVES CAUSED BY WILDFIRES WHEN
CITIES AND COUNTIES LOSE
RESIDENTS AND OUR TAX BASE. THE
AMOUNT OF RESOURCE AVAIL PAY
FOR LOCAL UPKEEP SUFFERS.
COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS WOULD SERVE
TO HIGHLIGHT LOCAL CULTURE AS
WELL AS PROVIDE ANY NUMBER OF
DESIRE FOR A FUNCTIONS.
INCLUDING SHELTER IN PLACE
ORDERS. ARE CONSISTENTLY
UNDERFUNDED AND IN DISREPAIR.
AND THAT'S NOT THE MEANT TO BE
INSULTED IT JUST TO KIND OF
SAY. IT'S WELL FOR US AT THE
STATE LEVEL TO TAKE NOTE OF
THESE THINGS BECAUSE THEY
AFFECT QUALITY OF LIFE IN THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
RESIDENTS. LOCAL ROADS
MAINTAINED BY COUNCILS HAVE
YEARS OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
WHICH AFFECT POTENTIAL
EVACUATION ROUTES FOR
RESIDENTS. AS WELL AS CRITICAL
ACCESS FOR FIRST RESPONDERS.
SMALL TOWNS AND UNINCORPORATED
ERRORS HAVE NO FUNDING
MECHANISMS TO REPAIR OR BRING
UP THE CODE. HISTORICALLY
SIGNIFICANT BUILDINGS FOR THE
COMMUNITY TO ENJOY. I KNOW THAT
TO BE TRUE THEORETICALLY BUT
I'VE SEEN THAT IN MY DISTRICT.
AND IT PAINS ME. AB FOURTEEN
FORTY SEVEN NICK RURAL
CALIFORNIA INFRASTRUCTURE ACT.
APPROPRIATES ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDS FOR GRANTS TO
SPECIAL DISTRICTS INDEPENDENT
FIRE DISTRICTS OR COUNTIES WITH
POPULATIONS LESS THAN THREE
THOUSAND FOR RURAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
INCLUDING FOR GROUND
MAINTENANCE DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS HI WERE STREET
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR OR
HISTORICAL OR CULTURAL
PRESERVATION REPAIR. IT
PROPOSED THAT THE FUNDS WOULD
BE OVERSEEN ALLOCATED BY
COMMITTEE WITH APPOINTMENTS
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT. OF C.
SACK AND THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES WOULD HAVE
APPOINTEES AS WELL AS FROM THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP. AND THE FOCUS WOULD
BE UPON PROJECTS THAT ARE
SHOVEL READY. SO WE'RE ACTUALLY
TALKING ABOUT GETTING DOLLARS
TO PROJECT CAN HAPPEN NOW.
FUNDS CAN ALSO BE USED TO
LEVERAGE OTHER SOURCE OF
FUNDING STRUCTURE FOR FEDERAL
PROGRAMS. AND I BELIEVE THIS
WILL ACTUALLY HELP WITH THESE
TYPES OF CREWS DEAL WITH JUST
PROJECTS WHICH- ARE. TOO BIG TO
FIND LOCALLY BUT NOT SO BIG
REALLY ACCESS OTHER SOURCES OF
FUNDS WAS REALLY. TO FOR THE
STATE TO LOOK AROUND A STEP
INTO A GAP. WHERE WE CAN
RELEASE ENERGY AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. OUR. I RECEIVED FEEDBACK
FROMA NUMBER OF GROUPS
SPECIFICALLY THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES THERE OF COURSE ALMOST
NO GROUP MORE DEEPLY INVEST IN
THE FUTURE OF OUR STATE AND OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THINGS A
SUPPORTER QUALIFY FOR THE
BUILDING TRADES THEY HAVE A
KEEN INTEREST IN HOW THIS BILL
WOULD WORK AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THEM REACHING OUT TO BE ALSO
REGIONAL CULTURAL COUNTY
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ORGANIZATION.
AND I INTEND TO WORK WITH ALL
AND FOR SERVICE FOR THE
BUILDING TRADES BECAUSE ARM. I
CERTAINLY WANT- DEPENDABLE
QUALITY IN AN EMERGENCY
INVOLVED. IN OUR STATE WITHOUT
AN VERGE FROM THE STATE RURAL
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA WILL
CONTINUE TO SUFFER CONTINUOUSLY
PUBLISHED LOSS OF AND I THINK
IT'S A- I THINK IT IS A- ALL
SOME STEP FOR US AT THE STATE
LEVEL TO LOOK AT OUR- WHOLE
STATE. AND ASK HOW CAN WE STEP
UP AND SUPPORT THOSE RESIDENTS
TO CALIFORNIA SOME OF THE MORE
RURAL PARTS OF THE STATE WHERE
FUNDING CAN BE AN ISSUE. SO
THAT THEIR DREAMS OF WHAT IT
MEANS TO LIVE IN THEIR
COMMUNITY AND TO. ENJOY LIFE
TOGETHER CAN BE SUPPORTED BY
THE ENTIRE STATE OF SO I THINK
IT'S TOUGH ENFORCEMENT AND
THERE COMMITTEE BUT REALLY IN
OUR DEMOCRACY. AW HERE TO
TESTIFY SUPPORT I DO BELIEVE ON
THE PHONE IS GOING TO BE JEFF
NEAL. OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES FOR
TURNER MISTER NEAL FEELS
AVAILABLE NOW. PRAGER YOU HAVE-
WHEN THIS IN SUPPORT. YES JEFF
NEAL HERE MISTER CHAIR. HAPPY
TO BE HERE TO SUPPORT IT THE
FOURTEENTH FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY. I'M WITH
THE COURT THE BILL FOR A COUPLE
OF REASONS- FIRST OF ALL
BECAUSE I HAVE BEEN BEEN WHAT'S
A SURPRISE TO MANY PEOPLE- ALL
THIS TO A COUNTY REVENUES HAVE
HAVE- IN IN GENERAL IN MANY
COUNTIES HAVE NOT BEEN GROWING.
AT THE SAME WAY THAT STATEWIDE
REVENUES HAVE PARTLY BECAUSE OF
THE REVENUE SOURCE AND- PARTLY
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THE OF
THE GREAT RECESSION- IF YOU
TAKE OUT A COUPLE OF THE LARGE
COUNTIES. THAT MANY COUNTIES
IMPACT HELP LOWER PER CAPITA I
TAX REVENUE- THAN THEY DID OVER
TEN YEARS AGO- WHICH WHICH I
THINK IS IT SHOCKING AND OF
COURSE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLEY POINTED OUT. THAT MANY
OF THESE COUNTY CIVIL IN
NATURE- AND SO ON TOP OF THIS
LACKLUSTER REVENUE GROWTH THAT
MANY COUNTY SUCCEED- THE SIZE
THE SCALE. OF THE DISASTERS
THAT HAVE BEFALLEN MANY OF THE
AREAS OF OUR STATE MADE IT VERY
DIFFICULT. AND IT YOU KNOW
THERE'S A THERE'S PROPERTY TAX
REIMBURSEMENT FOR A YEAR AND A
HALF- YOU KNOW A PROPERTY TAX
SUPPORT. FOR FIRE AFFECTED
DISASTER AFFECTED PROPERTY
WHICH TEMA REIMBURSEMENT THAT
THEY CAN HELP. OUT BELOW THAT
SOMETIMES YEARS THAT COME IN
BUT ASIDE FROM FROM THOSE AT
MANY OF THESE AREAS ARE ARE
LEFT TO FEND FOR THEMSELVES IN
THE WAKE OF THESE DISASTERS AND
MANY OF THEM DON'T HAVE THE TAX
BASE TO. TO DO SO AS QUICKLY OR
AS EFFECTIVELY. AS THEY WOULD
LIKE. AND SO. HAVE KIND OF
ISSUE. FOR THE FAIRGROUNDS THAT
NOT A- THAT SERVER IMPORTANT
ROLE DURING THE BECAUSE THAT.
BUT ALSO IMPORTANT CULTURE HUB
AT TIMES TO HAVE THE ASSISTANCE
WITH THE- ROADWAYS. AS WE'VE
SEEN THERE ARE OUT OF FUNDS
LIKE THAT THE HIGHWAY SAFETY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM AND A
HIGHWAY BRIDGE PROGRAMS ARE TO
ACTUALLY OVERSUBSCRIBED I THINK
THERE'S- YEARS WORTH OF
PROJECTS- THAT COULD BE FUNDED
AT THE CURRENT FUNDING LEVELS
IN THOSE. IN THOSE PROGRAMS. SO
THE FUNDING THAT THE BILL WOULD
REALLY GO A LONG WAY TO HELPING
EACH. COMMUNITY BAND. THE BLUE
RIBBON. THEMSELVES AND EDMUNDO
SO WE ARE PRETTY. THIS BILL IN
OUR TO IT. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. OPERATOR ANYONE ELSE ON
THE PHONE SUPPORT. THEN LATE
JUDGMENTS ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN ONE ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT OF AB. FOURTEEN
FORTY SEVEN. WE DO HAVE ONE IN
THE QUEUE TO BE JUST A MOMENT.
YEAH WE DO HAVE ONE IN THEIR
QUEUE- WILL GO TO NUMBER TWENTY
THREE. A LINE TWENTY THREE YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS RICHARD
MARCUSSEN FOR THE AMERICAN
SOCIETY OF CIVIL ENGINEERS.
NINETEEN THOUSAND CIVIL
ENGINEERS AND PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE PRACTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN FORTY
SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MR THANK YOU AS ERNIE
ELSON SUPPORT IN THE ROOM.
BURNER VIDEO CONFERENCE. SEEN
NONE OPERATORS ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
LINE. NOW IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION- THE P. B. FOURTEEN
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MR. THANK YOU AS OR
ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION- VIA VIDEO. SINAN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY WANTED
THANK YOU FOR AUTHORIZING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL ARE FOR GROUNDS-
IN PARTICULAR ARE CENTURY NOW.
DARK COMMUNITIES AT RISK. AND
IN A CRISIS HAS BEEN PROVEN
TIME AND TIME AGAIN THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS I LOOK FOR
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AT THIS
TIME- JUST BRING BACK TO THEM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND QUESTIONS
SUMMARY. THANK YOU- THIS CHAIR
MEMBERS. MR COOLEY I LIKE THE
SUBJECT LINE. RURAL CALIFORNIA
INFRASTRUCTURE ACT AND I LIKE
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING
TO PUT A BILLION DOLLARS
ALTHOUGH I'M NOT SURE GIVEN THE
HUGE AMOUNT OF ONE TIME MONEY
OR GET THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
I'M NOT SURE THAT IS REAL
CALIFORNIA'S FAIR SHARE SEEMS
LIKE MAYBE A START. BUT- I
WOULD CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE YOU
TO MAYBE START A LITTLE BIGGER
HERE ON THE FRONT END IN ONE
TIME MONEY- THE OTHER THING
THAT. JUST GIVES ME A LITTLE
BIT OF CONCERN IS THE WROTE
COVER INFRASTRUCTURE COMMITTEE.
YOU'VE GOT AN APPOINTEE BY THE
GOVERNOR. THE SPEAKER THE PRO
TEM COUPLE MEMBERS FROM C.
SACK. CALPERS LEAVE COMFORT
CITIES. I MEAN I HAVE. LITTLE
TO NO CONFIDENCE IN SOME OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS PARTICULAR
THE SPEAKER ON THIS DEMO IN THE
WORST SPEAKERS FOR RURAL
CALIFORNIA. IN SOMETIME SO I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE NEED L. A.
MEMBERS SAN DIEGO MEMBERS SAN
FRANCISCO FOLKS APPOINTING
PEOPLE TO CONTINUE TO.
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST THE VALLEY
WHICH IS REALLY WHAT WE'VE SEEN
SO. I KNOW IF YOU'RE OPEN TO A
BUT I'D LIKE TO SEE. MAYBE A
CHANGING COMPOSITION TO THE
COMMITTEE. I'D LIKE TO SEE.
MAYBE SOME MORE SPECIFICITY-
ITALY SOME OF THE BIG PROJECTS
RIGHT WE PASSED A WATER BOND
HERE IN TWENTY FOURTEEN- WITH
THE PROMISE OF BUILDING WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE MOST NOTABLY TWO
BIG PROJECTS TEMPERANCE FLAT
AND FRESNO INSIGHTS RESERVOIR
NORTH SACRAMENTO NEITHER OF
WHICH HAVE GOTTEN EVEN MOVE
DIRT- IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SO
WE'VE GOT A REALLY POOR TRACK
RECORD. WHEN WE LEAVE THE
SPENDING UP TO OUTSIDE GROUPS
WHETHER IT'S THE WATER
COMMISSION IN THIS CASE IT'S
THIS COMMITTEE THAT WERE
ESTABLISHING- SO I GUESS. THE
OVER THE TEN YEARS I'VE BEEN
HERE I'M START TO LOSE
CONFIDENCE WHEN WE'RE NOT A
LITTLE BIT MORE SPECIFIC IN OUR
SPENDING CHOICES RIGHT AND I
THINK WE'VE GOT A BUDGET
PROCESS TO DO THAT. WE
CERTAINLY HAVE SOME GREAT
MEMBERS RURAL CALIFORNIA SOME
OF WHICH ARE ON THIS COMMITTEE-
YOURSELF AND OTHERS WHO COULD
GET INVOLVED IN REALLY LAYING
OUT HERE'S THE SPECIFIC
PROJECTS AND ENSURING EVERY
REGION EVERY COUNTY GETS THEIR
FAIR SHARE BECAUSE I JUST
THINK- IN RECENT MEMORY WE'VE
HAD. A RELATIVELY POOR TRACK
RECORD OF FOLLOWING THROUGH.
ASK THE TALKING POINTS OF A
MAJOR STRUCTURE INVESTMENT AND
AGAIN JUST TO FINISH UP. LOTS
OF ONE TIME FEDERAL MONEY LOTS
OPPORTUNITY. YOU'VE
DEMONSTRATED AND ARTICULATED IN
THIS BUILD LOTS OF NEED- AND
YEARS OF. INADEQUATE INVESTMENT
RIGHT AND- SO ALL THE LEVERS
SEVERAL QUESTIONS ARE FOR YOU
TO RESPOND TO BUT- IF YOU'RE
OPEN LIKE TO THE COMMITTEE.
CHANGE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
COMMITTEE- COMPOSITION AND SOME
MORE SPECIFIC PROJECTS- AND
SOME MORE MONEY. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
CICILLINE. THANK YOU ARE NOT
YOU KNOW I'M A BIG PROPONENT OF
FAIRGROUNDS BUT WHEN I HAVE MY
CONCERN IS THAT SAYS THE- ALL
THE BILL WOULD PROVIDE A
BILLION DOLLAR GRANTS TO SMALL
COUNTIES AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
BLAH BLAH BLAH- FOR THOSE
GRANTS ARE THEY GOING TO DO
DOES THE COUNTIES HAVE TO MATCH
THOSE GRANTS AND IF SO THAT'S
IS VERY. TROUBLESOME TO ME
BECAUSE IF THEY DON'T HAVE
MONEY AND A LOT OF TIMES GRANTS
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE A MATCH AND
SO I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
PIECE OF IT. WITHOUT ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER QUESTION YEAH
I THINK THE MEMBER FOR BRING IT
FOR IT I MEAN THERE DEFINITELY
NEEDS TO BE- INVESTMENT IN
RURAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND I
THINK EVERYBODY AGREES WITH
THAT I WOULD SAY ON THE ON THE
TASK FORCE I THINK THAT WOULD
BE SOMETHING I'D LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOU TO ON. YOU KNOW WHAT
WHO SHOULD BE COMPOSED OF THAT
MY CONCERN ACTUALLY SEE SACK
NOTORIOUSLY BEEN NOT VERY GOOD
FOR RURAL COUNTIES- OFTENTIMES
IS VERY MUCH. DOES A LOT OF
THINGS FOR URBAN COUNTIES BUT
RURAL COUNTIES OFTEN GET LEFT
BEHIND- AND THAT'S ONLY
CONTINUE TO BE MY EXPERIENCE
SINCE I LEFT BEING A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR AND NOW BEING A
LEGISLATURE SO I'M NOT SURE IF
THEY'RE THE BEST ORGANIZATION-
TO BE ON THE OTHER BUT IT
OBVIOUSLY THAT THE INTENT HERE
IS TO GET TO SOMETHING THAT. IS
GOING TO PUT REAL MONEY INTO
GREATER EVERLASTING OF SUPPORT
OF THAT CONCEPT WOULD JUST LIKE
TO WORK WITH YOU ON. YOU KNOW
WHAT THAT. ENTITY SHOULD BE
COMPOSED OF AND- YOU KNOW HOW
WE ENSURE THAT THERE'S GONNA BE
A REAL FOCUS ON ROLES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WITHOUT A REPORT
SUPPORTING THE BILL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I DO WANT TO SAY- FIRST OFF I
WAS REMISS IN NOT GOING TO
NOTING THAT MIKE CORCORAN THIS
IS MY COLLEAGUE FRANK BIGELOW.
OF WHOM I GOT TO KNOW BEFORE WE
WERE MEMBERS- I WANT TO NOTE
THAT PART OF THE. WAY A VERY
EXPRESSWAY THE BILL IS DESIGNED
IS. ONLY COUNTIES WITH
POPULATION THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND UNDER ARE ELIGIBLE
SO THERE'S AN AWFUL LOT OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ACTUALLY IN A
STATEWIDE PROGRAM ACTUALLY
WRITTEN OUT OF IT AT THE
BEGINNING- I WOULD SAY THAT MY
INTERPRETATION OF HOW THIS
WOULD APPLY. IS UNLESS YOU ARE
IF YOU ARE AN ACCOUNTING OF
THREE THOUSAND OR MORE. IF YOU
HAVE AN INDEPENDENT FIRE
DISTRICT. OR A SMALL SPECIAL
DISTRICT THEY WOULD ACTUALLY BE
ABLE TO APPLY BUT IT DOESN'T
APPLY TO BIG COUNTIES- SO WE'RE
ACTUALLY STARTED WITH THIS A
RISK CONSTRICTED UNIVERSAL WHO
WOULD BE THE ELIGIBLE COUNTIES
I REALLY WAS DESIGNED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE RESOURCE OF COAL
OR THE WEATHER INTENDED TO GO.
TO ADDRESS YOUR CONCERNS. ON
SAUDI TENDED. I ACTUALLY FEEL
THAT I'M OPEN ON THE GOVERNANCE
ISSUES I WOULD NOT WISH TO TAKE
A MOMENT HERE BUT I THINK THE
GENERAL STRUCTURE IS ONE THAT-
WE USE OF SO MANY THINGS BUT I
THINK THE- THE SUBSTANCE OF.
THIS ACT WHICH LIMITS FOR THE
DOLLARS COULD FLOW. SO I'M LESS
CONCERNED ON THE ISSUE OF. WHO
DOES WHAT APPOINTMENTS- AND
THEN I DO WANT TO SAY THAT THE
WAY THE LAW IS STRUCTURED. OF.
ASSEMBLY MAGYAR COREY OUR-
LOCAL AGES AWARD A GRANT OF
THIS CHAPTER. MAY ADDITIONALLY
LEVERAGE FEDERAL OR PRIVATE
FUNDING OR PRIVATE PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIPS TO COMPLETE THEIR
PROJECT THE GRANT WAS AWARDED.
FOR THE FUNDS THAT'S GREAT. BUT
IT'S NOT IT'S LIKE THEY THEY
PUTS THE PROJECT AT A SHOVEL
READY THAT MEETS ONE OF THESE
CRITERIA. AND I DO THINK THAT
THERE'S ONGOING CONVERSATION
ABOUT SHOULD THERE BE. OUR
REFINEMENTS THAT BY TO COMPLAIN
WATER PROJECTS THAT ARE DEEMED
IMPORTANT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
R. DID- OUR STORM WATER WHICH
WOULD BE SORT OF INTERTWINED
WITH CLEAN WATER. BUT SO I
THINK. I ACTUALLY. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I STARTED A
CONVERSATION MR BRICKELL LAST
FALL ABOUT. AN IDEA THAT I
THINK IT'S ONE THAT AS AN
INSTITUTION WE COULD PUT OUR
ARMS AROUND. I VIEW IT IS VERY
MALLEABLE BUT I'D LIKE TO. I
FACTOR REFLECT ON CHANGES
BEFORE I MAKE THAT HAVE LONG
WAY TO GO I ALSO YOU KNOW. I'LL
SAY THIS FOR A NEW OF THE
AMERICAN RECOVERY ACT A BILLION
DOLLARS IT'S NOT A BIG NUMBER
IN TERMS OF CALIFORNIA BUT IT
IS FOR LOOKS DIFFERENT NOW.
OTHER THERE MAY BE OTHER THINGS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE- I
PERSONALLY WOULD STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE LEGISLATURE.
FINDING WAYS TO TARGET SUPPORT.
TO THOSE CALIFORNIA RURAL
COUNTIES. SO THAT THEY AT
LEAST. THEY CAN FEEL GRUMPY
FROM TIME TO TIME WHAT WE DO
HERE AT THE STATE CAPITOL BUT
THERE ARE A PART OF OUR OUR
STATE. AND I REALLY FEEL THIS
BILL IS ABOUT PUTTING THE STATE
GOVERNMENT APOSTROPHE RESPECT
AND HONOR TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
ON FIVE LIKE THE I'D ADD
TALKING TO VOLUNTEER PROGRAM
THEY ARE NOT IS TO ADD TO
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE IS CO
AUTHORS UNTIL WITH A LOT TO DO
BUT. I DEFINITELY IT'S- TIED.
THE OTHER FOR. ASYLUM ACTOR
FOR. OPERAS LOCALLY TO THERE IS
GRANTS UNDER THIS FOR TO LIVE
OTHER FOR SOURCE TO PRO YES BUT
AS TO. FOR THAT IS CORRECT.
SUMMARY ARTICLE YEAH I JUST
WANTED TO. DIALOGUE IT'S OKAY
CHAIR SECOND WITH MYSTICAL BUT-
I DON'T AGREE. TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IS LAW OF MONEY IN MY
YEARS RIGHT IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
SUCH A ENORMOUS BUT SOMETIME
IT'S WE LOOSE OF THAT I GUESS
COMIC STRIP AT THIS BODY JUST
MANY ORGAN AND A CEASE CITIES
OR THE CALIFORNIA RESOURCES.
TEND TO GET DOMINATED BY THE
URBAN MEMBERSHIP. RIGHT WE HAVE
A SPEAKER FROM ALLY WE HAVE A
PROTON FROM SAN DIEGO WE HAVE A
GOVERNOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
AND THE REST OF US LIVE IN A
LOT OF DIFFERENT PLACES AND
OFTENTIMES ARE REPRESENTED. AND
SO JUST CONCERNS ME THAT PEOPLE
BRING. ATTITUDES AND IDEOLOGIES
IN THE ROLE CALIFORNIA THE
APPROPRIATE- PERFECT EXAMPLE
WE'VE INCREASED OUR WATER.
STORAGE INFRASTRUCTURE BY 1% IN
THE LAST FORTY YEARS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S A FACT
MEMBERS SO WE'VE DOUBLED OUR
POPULATION. AND WE'VE INCREASED
OUR CAPACITY TO STORE WATER BY
1% AND WE ALL SIT AROUND OH MY
GOD THERE'S A DROUGHT HOW DO WE
FIX IT HOME YOU MAY BE BUILT
SOME INSTRUCTIONS ON. I SO I
THESE FOLKS STEERING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE COMMITTEE WALK
ALBEIT YOU'VE LIMITED THE
SPENDING TO THE TWENTY EIGHT
COUNTIES I GUESS THAT FALL
UNDER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND IS
THAT RIGHT- THEY START
ENFORCING COMMUNITY IT'S
ARGUABLY QUESTIONABLE HOW WE
COULD HAVE A RURAL
INFRASTRUCTURE ACT WITHOUT A
DAMMIT. RIGHT GIVEN OUR WATER
PROBLEMS BUT I KNOW THE REASON
THERE'S NOT A IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILLS BECAUSE IT'S
CONTROVERSIAL WITH URBAN
POLITICS RIGHT NOT
CONTROVERSIAL WITH THOSE OF US
THAT REPRESENT RURAL CALIFORNIA
FACTORS ARE. PRETTY IMPRESSIVE-
CONSENSUS A REPUBLICAN DEMOCRAT
AND CENTRIST IN ROCK CALIFORNIA
TO MOVE FOR WITH THESE PROJECTS
BUT THESE OUTSIDE INTERESTS ALL
WE DON'T WANT TO INVEST IN THAT
IT'S HUNDRED CENTER SO THOSE
ARE NOT JUST TO REALLY DRILL
DOWN THAT CONCERNED THAT GIVES
ME PAUSE SOME OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND IN STATEWIDE
LEADERSHIP AREN'T NECESSARILY.
SUPPORTIVE OF OUR NEEDS AND
THAT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S A
BETTER WAY TO DO THAT I'M
CERTAINLY PREPARED TO VOTE FOR
THE BILL TODAY AS IS WITHOUT
ANY AMENDMENTS- BUT CERTAIN
WOULD APPRECIATE REAL
CONSIDERATION ON. HOW WE DON'T
REPEAT THE EPIC FAILURE OF THE
TWENTY FOURTEEN WATER BOND
WHERE WE ALL GO TO A LOT OF
HASSLE TO PUT TOGETHER A
BIPARTISAN DEAL GET A LOT OF
MONEY AND THEN THE MONEY
SOMEHOW. YOU KNOW GOES TO THE-
WATER COMMISSION AND GETS
SIPHONED OFF BY LA AND SAN
FRANCISCO TO OTHER. PURPOSES
YEAH. SO AT THAT GONNA WE HAVE.
A W. WE HAVE THE MOST AND
SECOND. SECTOR THEN WILL TO
MAKE MORE. DO WE MOTION. THE
AMERICAN MACOMB HAVE A. SECOND
BY SOME REWARD SO THAT
SECRETARY CALLED. MOTION ISSUE
PASSAGE ECONOMIC THE IN THE
ECONOMY RATHER HI BUT I TO AYE
SECTOR I AYE GUARD THE VOTING I
GOT CARRYING OUT VOTING
CALDERON RIGHT CALDERON I
DOLLAR. GALLAGHER I GRADE. FIVE
GREAT I WARD WARD FIVE THERE
SIX. WHAT THAT THE MOVE OUT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
WORKING. FIVE NOW WE'LL GO TO
FARM THE. ONE EIGHT ELEVEN
HUNDRED. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CURRY
WOULD YOU'RE READY. WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MOVE THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MAY I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT A BE ABLE
HOW BUT YOU'RE THE PA YOU TO
COMMISSION TO PLAY INFORMATION
THE PUBLIC. SERVICE PROVIDER
SEPARATES TO REPAIR SHE REPLACE
NETWORK INTEREST OF EMERGE FOR
DOES THAT. THE WILDFIRES OF
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHT HI
MASS DEFICIT FOR PROPERTY TO
TALK. YEAH DAMAGE. MANY
REPORTED THAT THE PHONE WENT
AND INTERNET SO WENT FOR A CELL
TOWER WERE DAM AND UNDER BY
LINES BURNED. IN TWO THOUSAND
SO AND ON SURVEY FOUND THIS PER
PERCENT OF CONSIDER COUNTY WELL
FOR AFFECTED AREAS LOS PHONE
THROUGH. JUST LAST YEAR THE TWO
TWENTY THE GLASS FIRE REPORTED
DAMAGETHE CAN. OF THE HOW JUST.
IN FOR THROUGH IN THE AREA. IN%
THE AFTERMATH OF THESE
DEVASTATING FIRES THE STATE IN
P. C. HAVE FOCUSED HEAVILY ON
THE UTILITIES RESPONSE TO THE
MASS OF DESTRUCTION. EVEN TODAY
LITTLE IS KNOWN ABOUT THE FULL
IMPACT THESE NATURAL DISASTERS
HAVE HAD ON TELECOMMUNICATIONS
NETWORKS AND HOW
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES
HAVE RESPONDED. THANK RECOVERY
PLANS ARE NOT SHARED WITH THE
P. C. OR THE LEGISLATURE WHOSE
JOB IT IS TO OVERSEE THESE
COMPANIES THAT REPRESENT THE
PUBLIC'S INTEREST. WE NEED THIS
INFORMATION TO MAKE SURE THE
GOVERNMENT THE GOVERNMENT ARE
HELPING IN THIS REPAIR EFFORTS
AND NOT IMPEDING RESTORATION.
AB ELEVEN HUNTERDON ELEMENT
HUNDRED CARDS THE PC TO COLLECT
INFORMATION ON
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDERS EFFORTS TO REPAIR
REPLACE NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE
AFTER THE EMERGENCIES AND
DISASTERS. I WANT TO STRESS
THAT THIS BILL REQUIRED
REPORTING IS NOT MANDATED TO
MEET SUBMITTED DURING THE
EMERGENCIES THEMSELVES BUT IT
IS INSTEAD A LOOK BACK TO MAKE
SURE GOVERNMENT AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR WORKING TOGETHER TO
PROVIDE SOLUTIONS IN THE SHORT
TERM DURING EMERGENCIES. AND
APPROPRIATE SERVICE TO SUPPORT
LOCAL ECONOMIES AFTER THE
DISASTER IN THE LONG TERM. AB
ELEVEN HUNDRED ISN'T IS NEEDED
TO ENSURE THAT STATE REGULATORS
AND PUBLIC OFFICIALS OR FORM TO
THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
FAILURES. AND THAT WERE DAMAGED
AFTER THE NATURAL DISASTER.
WITHOUT INFORMATION REGARDING
THE METHODS AND TECHNOLOGIES TO
REBUILD THERE IS NO WAY TO
ENSURE THAT RESIDENTS HAVE THE
SAME FOR IMPROVED ACCESS TO A
RELIABLE NETWORK. FOR MORE MOST
CALIFORNIANS RELIABLE VOICE
TELEPHONE SERVICES NECESSARY TO
REACH NINE ONE ONE. WITHOUT IT
THE ABILITY TO CONTACT
EMERGENCY SERVICES IS LIMITED
OR NONEXISTENT. WITH ME TO
TESTIFIED ON THE PHONE AND
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR
BRINDABELLA NORWAY ABOUT OF
TURN TELECOM AS WELL AS FRANK
HARRIS SAY THE C. W. A.
DISTRICT NOW THANK YOU.
OPERATOR WE HAVE WITH.
INDIVIDUALS ON THE PHONE FOR
SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE BOTH
WITNESSES ONLINE- YOUR LINES
ARE OPEN. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
HAD CHARACTER THAT HE GETS THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS BRENDA IBM WENT ABOUT
REPRESENTING TURN. I THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
ABOUT AB ELEVEN HUNDRED TURN IS
A CO SPONSOR THE SPELL AND
BANKS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY FOR LEADERSHIP ON
STATION. GIVEN TO THAT SINCE
THE WAR AT THIS. WE SEE AN
COLLEGE GAP ABOUT THE CREE QUE
NETWORK AND INFRASTRUCTURE AND-
EIGHT DECISION MAKERS HAVE
BENEFIT FROM. INFORMATION OR
OUT EXTRA. HOWEVER ALLOW
HUNDRED EIGHT TAKES ITS KERN
WORK EXCEPT FOR THEIR- IF THEY
WOULD REQUIRE TO SEE FEATURE
COURT. TO LET'S. IN FOR ABOUT
LONG TERM. FINANCIAL USED TO RE.
COMMUNICATION THAT. DAMAGED IN
A ACT. AND NEVER ABOUT OBSTACLE
FACED IN THE REBEL. IN THIS
WORK WE ALREADY RECEIVED SOME
INFORMATION NEEDED TO PREPARE
FOR. THEIR FOR THIS BILL NEED
NOT BE AN ADDITIONAL CARE
REQUIREMENTS NOR DOES IT DIVERT
CARRIER FOCUSED. FROM SERVICE
RESTORATION. THIS BILL REQUIRES
THE C. CORTES EVERY OBSTACLE.
INVESTIGATORS THE LEGISLATION
GOVERNMENTS WILL BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS YOUR SEATS
IN REBUILDING AND FINALLY THE
BILL STRUCK THE PROPER BALANCE
TO HONOR BALICK CONFIDENTIALITY
CONCERNS WHILE PROVIDING
SUFFICIENT KNOWLEDGE TO KEY
DECISION MAKERS. THIS BILL WILL
NOT. IMPACT THE CURRENT
POLITICAL. NOW TODAY TO MADE
ESPECIALLY ESPECIALLY THOSE
SERVING BUSINESS AFTER AREAS
NEED INFORMATION CAN MAKE
IMPORTANT LONG TERM LOGISTICS
DECISION. AB ELEVEN HUNDRED WE
BELIEVE IT'S A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
OPERATOR TO HAVE SOMEONE ELSE
ALONG FOR SUPPORT. THE TOP
FRANK OUR SAY. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM FRANK OUTFIT AND I
AM THE DISTRICT NINE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR THE COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA. YOUR CALL
SPONSORED OF A BILL OF A
HUNDRED. MR NINE COVERS
CALIFORNIA NEVADA HAWAII AND
GUAM WE ARE PERCENT WORKERS IN
THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
AND A BROAD SPECTRUM OF OTHER
INDUSTRIES. WE ASK THAT YOU
PASSED SB ELEVEN HUNDRED. TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATIONS AND BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE IS FULLY AND
PROPERLY RESTORED FOLLOWING THE
DECLARED STATE OF EMERGENCY.
STATE OF THE WAY MEMBERS ARE
THE ONES WHO ARE SENT OUT TO
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. WHAT THAT IS URBAN
OR RURAL TO RESTORE SERVICE AND
WE BUILD CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WHEN THERE IS
DAMAGE CAUSED BY A WIDE VARIETY
OF EVENTS. OUR WORKERS ARE THE
ONES TRYING TO GET FAMILIES
BACK ONLINE AND BACK CONNECTION.
OUR GOAL IS AND SHOULD BE TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY HOME. EVERY
HOME IS BACK UP AND RUNNING IN
THE SHORTEST TIME POSSIBLE AND
THE MOST EFFECTIVE MEANS
POSSIBLE FOR LONG TERM SERVICE
THE STATE ABILITY. TO OFTEN ARE
WORKERS SUFFERED FROM CUSTOMERS
THAT NOT. THAT NOT ONLY WITH
THEIR SERVICE INTERRUPTED
BECAUSE OF AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION. BUT THAT THE SERVICE
IS NOT BE STORED FOR PROLONG
PERIOD. EVIL MANY OTHER
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE BACK ONLINE.
THE COMPANY'S TO PLAY THAT THEY
THE FISH BACK UP POWER CAPACITY
TO KEEP NETWORKS OPERATING
DURING POWER OUTAGES. BUT ANY
FIELD TECHNICIAN COULD TELL YOU
THAT IT IS CRACKED UP FIXES ARE
NOT GOOD ENOUGH. FOR EXAMPLE
TECHNICIANS PHYSICALLY
CONNECTING TO TERMINAL TO
PROVIDE GENERATOR BACKUP BLIX
DRONES AND MOBILE TOWERS ON
TRUCKS. PROVIDE ONLY LIMITED
TEMPORARY COVERAGE. NOT A
REPLACEMENT FOR REAL BACK UP
POWER AND CONNECTIVITY. WE
CANNOT LET THIS HAPPEN WE MUST%
ENSURE THAT OUR COMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE RESTORED FOR
EVERY CUSTOMER. AB ELEVEN
HUNDRED WILL LET YOU LAY THE
GROUNDWORK TO ADDRESS HOW
PROVIDERS WE BUILD WHOLE
COMPLETED THESE AFTER
DISASTERS. ARE THEY INSTALLING
FIBER UPGRADES WHENEVER
POSSIBLE WHO ARE THEY DOING THE
BARE MINIMUM FOR PLACING OLD
COPPER WITH NEW COFFEE FLAVOR
NETWORK OUTDATED AND UNABLE TO
MEET TOMORROW AND TODAY'S
COMMUNICATION NEEDS. WE MUST
ENSURE THAT THESE COMMUNITIES
NETWORKS SHOULD BE REBUILT WITH
FIBER ON THE CABLES INSTEAD OF
COPPER. TOO MANY TIMES BUT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
HAVE STONE UPLOAD BLOCKS TO
STOP LEGISLATION LIKE THIS. WE
OWE IT TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND ESPECIALLY TO
OUR CHILDREN TO LEARN THE
LESSONS OF THE PANDEMIC AND THE
WILDFIRES AND TO RESTORE
ABILITY TO HOLD PROVIDERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE PEOPLE THEY
SERVE. AB ELEVEN HUNDRED TAKES
IMPORTANT STEPS TOWARDS GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY AND WE ASK YOU
TO SUPPORT AB. ELEVEN HUNDRED.
THANK YOU. THANK OPERATE
WITHOUT IS THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. ANY
WITNESSES- VIA CONFERENCE LINE.
OPERATORS ANY OF ANYONE ELSE ON
THE LINE IN SUPPORT. FOR AB
ELEVEN HUNDRED FAMILIES JUST.
PLEASE JOIN INSURANCE SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN HUNDRED PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
HUNDRED. WE DO HAVE ONE IN THE
QUEUE TO BE JUST A MOMENT. THEN
WE'LL GO OVER TO LINE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. LET'S ARE
INTENSELY W. A DISTRICT NINE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. AND AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. THIS TIME THERE ARE
NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR. THANK
OPERATE WITHOUT TO DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM OR IN A WE DO HAVE
SOMEONE IN THE ROOM. WITH THAT
PLEASE COME FORWARD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BERNIE OROZCO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CABLE AND TELECOM
COMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION R.
C. C. T. A. IS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE- WE
FIND THIS- MEASURE TO BE A
REDUNDANT AND A HUGE A
SUBMISSION A REQUIREMENT FOR A
LITTLE PUBLIC BENEFIT I THINK
THE ANALYSIS DID A GREAT JOB IN
LISTING ALL THE REPORTS THAT
TODAY WE WERE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE WE HAVE TO FEDERAL
REPORTS THE- THE JURORS IN THE
NORSE REPORT NETWORK OUTAGE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT
IT'S BECOME BY THE- BY THE FCC
WE ALSO HAVE THE DERS
REQUIREMENT THE DISASTER
INFORMATION REPORTING SYSTEM
REPORTS. THESE REPORTS ABOUT
AVERAGES AND THE RESTORATION
EFFORTS SO IN ADDITION TO THAT-
THERE WAS LEGISLATION PASSED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THIS IS SB SIX
SEVENTY WHICH ALSO REQUIRES NOT
ONLY NETWORK OUTAGE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS BUT ALSO REQUIRES
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE FACILITIES
HOW LONG IT WILL TAKE TO
RESTORE THOSE FACILITIES AND
WHEN WERE THOSE FACILITIES
RESTORED. WHAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS REPORT THE
REPORT BY THAT MCGUIRE
LEGISLATION IN TWENTY NINETEEN
AND THE FEDERAL REPORTS IS THAT
THEY ARE CONFIDENTIAL SO I
THINK WHAT'S MISSING FROM THE
ANALYSIS IS ANY DISCUSSION
ABOUT CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
SO THE COMMUNICATIONS NETWORKS
THIS INDUSTRY SECTOR IS ONE OF
THE SIXTEEN SECTORSTHAT IS
CONSIDERED TO BE PROTECTED AND
THERE'S NO DISCUSSION ABOUT
THAT IN THIS SIR NGUYEN SB SIX
SEVENTY PASS. LEGISLATION
IMPLEMENTING THERE IS A
SPECIFIC PROVISION IN THAT
MEASURE THAT SAYS THIS
INFORMATION MAY NOT BE SHARED
OTHER THAN WITH LOCAL PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICIALS AND WITH THE
NINE ONE ONE CALL CENTERS
BEYOND THAT IT CANNOT BE SHARED
SO I KNOW THERE'S SOME LANGUAGE
IN HERE THAT THE PC CAN COME UP
WITH SOME REGULATIONS AND
RULES. AND ALTHOUGH WE WOULD
OPPOSE THIS MEASURE MOVING
FORWARD SHOULD THE MEASURE MOVE
FORWARD YOU JUST SAY WHAT YOU
MEAN AND MEAN WHAT YOU SAY IF
IT'S CONFIDENTIAL JUST SAY IT'S
CONFIDENTIAL THAT'S WHAT WE DID
IN SB SIX SEVENTY AND. THAT'S
WHAT YOU CAN DO HERE WITH THIS
ONE TODAY. SO IT'S- WHAT ARE
THE OTHER ISSUES THAT WE HAS
ABOUT THIS REAL TIME REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ALTHOUGH WE MAY
NOT HAVE TO SUBMIT A REAL TIME
REPORT TO SOMEONE SIT IN A DESK
IN SAN FRANCISCO WE STILL HAVE
TO COLLECT THAT INFORMATION AND
YOU COLLECT THAT INFORMATION AS
THE DISASTERS GOING ON SO THIS
REAL TIME DISCUSSION IS NOT
REALLY- IT IS AN ISSUE THAT IS
HAS ANY MERIT THAT IF YOU WERE
TO DELAY IT. YOU STILL NEED TO
DO IT SHOULD WE NOT SUBMIT THAT
INFORMATION SHOULD WE MISS
SOMETHING LATER ON IN A WE
COULD BE PENALIZED FOR THAT SO.
FAR OUR POSITION IS THAT. I
THINK. AFTER YOU LIST ALL THE
REPORTS ARE REQUIRED IN
ANALYSIS THE ONE BIG MISSING
PIECE WAS. WHAT IS BEING
PROVIDED. IN THIS BILL. THAT IS
NOT BEING PROVIDED IN THOSE
OTHER REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE- ISSUES
THAT WAS TOUCHED ON BY THE
PROPONENTS WITH THE TECHNOLOGY.
WHAT TECHNOLOGY DID YOU USE TO
RESTORE THAT NETWORK NOW WHEN
YOU PROVIDE NINE ONE ONE
SERVICE. THE PC HAS
JURISDICTION OVER WHAT IS THE
DEFINITION OF NINE ONE ONE WHAT
IS THE DEFINITION OF BASIC
TELEPHONE SERVICE BASIC
TELEPHONE SERVICE. IS ABILITY
TO MAKE AND I WON ONE PHONE
CALL. IT DOES NOT SPECIFY
TECHNOLOGY IF THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE GOVERNMENT WERE TO GET
INTO THE BUSINESS OF DECIDING
WHAT TECHNOLOGIES MORE PART IS
COPPER BETTER. THAN FIBER IS
FIBER BETTER THAN FIVE G. IS
FIVE YOU BETTER THAN SATELLITE.
THAT'S NOT A POSITION YOU WANT
TO BE SO- I THINK THE ONLY
THING I SEE IN THIS MEASURE.
WOULD BE A DISCUSSION ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY AND I DON'T THINK
YOU WANT TO GO THERE IN A GIVEN
OR DMV FIASCOS GIVEN ALL THE-
CONNECT YOU KNOW COMPUTER
GLITCHES THAT WE HAVE WITH
CALIFORNIA THAT'S PROBABLY NOT
A ROAD YOU WANT TO GO DOWN. FOR
THESE REASONS WERE OPPOSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM.
OPERATOR THERE EVER ANY
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION ONLINE.
AND LAYS IN GERMAN IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR.
OUR BRING BACK HERE TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- ANY COMMENTS
CONCERNS REMEMBERS. BY SHERRY
OF A QUESTION COMMENT IF YOU.
SO FAR AFTER NINE ELEVEN THERE
WAS A HUGE EFFORT AND IT'S
INTERESTING BEFORE THIS
GENTLEMAN CAME UP TO SPEAK IS
IN THE CONCERNS I HAD- AND THIS
EFFORT WAS- THE INTELLIGENCE
PART OF THIS AND IN OUR
SECURITY OUR NATIONAL SECURITY
AND BEING ABLE TO AND THEY
DEVELOP THE SAINTS COUGH J.
RICK JOINT REGIONAL
INTELLIGENCE HI COMMITTEE. AND
THEY TRAINED A LOT OF FIRST
RESPONDERS IN RECOGNIZING WHAT
SOME OF THESE INFRASTRUCTURE
INFRASTRUCTURE WEAKNESSES CAN
BE. AND THIS WAS ONE OF THEM.
THIS IS ONE OF- WHERE. DAY
RECOGNIZE THAT TOO MUCH
INFORMATION TO THE WRONG
PEOPLE. NOT ONLY LEAVES
COMMUNITIES VULNERABLE- BUT IT
ALSO- ENABLES. EXTENSIVE
PLANNING- BY PEOPLE NOT MY HAVE
NEFARIOUS IDEAS ABOUT WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO. AND AND THIS IS
THIS IS THE MAIN CONCERN I HAVE
WITH THIS. IS THERE IS THERE IS
A REDUNDANCY THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES COORDINATOR
IF YOU SEE RIGHT NOW. AND THEY
DO COLLECT THIS INFORMATION BUT
THEY DO KEEP IT MORE
CONFIDENTIAL- IF YOU CAN
IMAGINE A COMMUNITY THAT HAS
BEEN HARD HIT. AND THEY'RE
GETTING IN AND THE GENERAL
PUBLIC OUT THERE IS GETTING
CONSTANT UP UPDATES ON WHAT
THEY'RE VULNERABILITIES ARE
FROM A COMMUNICATION
STANDPOINT- DOES BECOME
TARGETS. FOR PEOPLE TO GO TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES AND- AND-
EITHER COMMIT YOU KNOW WHATEVER
TYPES OF- YOU KNOW BURGLARIES
ROBBERIES THAT SEPARATE SET
TRAPS. AND THOSE ARE THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE WITH THAT.
IS ACT I THINK WE HAVE A PLACE
AS A SYSTEM IN PLACE. TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT NOW WE HAVE A
COMMITTEE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO COORDINATE SO THAT WE
KIND OF HAVE AN IDEA. BUT IT
DOESN'T NEED TO BE I THINK IT
NEEDS TO STAY CONFIDENTIAL
BECAUSE IT IS ONE OF OUR
CRITICAL CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE- NO ISSUES HERE.
IN THE END NOT ONLY TO
CALIFORNIA BUT IN THE UNITED
STATES. SO FOR THOSE REASONS
I'M I'M A LITTLE I'M I'M I'M
PROBABLY GOING TO HAVE TO
OPPOSE IT FOR NOW AND- AND- YOU
KNOW. IF THERE'S SOME. SOME
ADDRESSING OF THOSE ISSUES IN
BETWEEN NOW AND COME TO THE
FLOOR- AND MY EARS ARE OPEN FOR
YOU. THANK ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. JOHNSON WITHOUT
COMMEMORATIVE BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I DO HAVE I RECKON
I WOULD JUST CONTINUE IF THE
BILL CONTINGENT BEFORE TO WORK
WITH OPPOSITION AND ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE ISSUES REGARDING
CONFIDENTIALITY WHICH SEEMS TO
BE COULD BE AN ISSUE BUT LONG
TO CONTINUE WORK THEM I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT SO WITH THAT ARE
BELIEVED TO HAVE A MOTION. I
WOULD BE SECOND WE HAVE A
MOTION OF A SECOND- SUMMER.
CALDERON HAS A SECOND SO WITH
THAT SECRETARY CALDERON MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
RODRIGUEZ HI ARE YOU GUYS I
THERE ARE STILL NO CERTAIN NO
AGUIAR-CURRY HI I GOT A GREAT
HI CALDERON CALDERO I
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER ABSENT
GRAY. GREAT JOB WARD FOR I.
DESPITE THE WITHOUT THE MO OUT
OF WILL HE LEAVE THE ROLE OF
MACHINE NUMBER. SO WITH THAT WE
HAVE WE LEFT- PHONE NUMBER FOR.
QUESTION WOULD YOU LIKE TO OVER
ONE I PRESENT TIME DO SO. SO
THIS ITEM IS A ON TWENTY.
ASSEMBLY RODRIGUEZ WHEN YOU ARE
READY. YOU MAY PRESENT. HAVE A
MOTION TO APPROVE BY WARD A
SECOND BY AGUILAR CURRY. THANK
YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ THANK YOU
FRAZIER MEMBERS ARE RIGHTS
PRESENT. AB ELEVEN TWENTY THREE
AND URGENCY MEASURE THAT WOULD
INCREASE THE LEGISLATURE
OVERSIGHT OF EXECUTIVE ACTIONS
ON EXPENDITURES MADE DURING A
PROCLAIMS STATE OF EMERGENCY.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL THAT
WILL HELP BRING A CHECK AND
BALANCE TO THE GOVERNOR'S BOARD
BURDEN SHE POWERS. ASIDE FROM A
THIRTY TO TERMINATE EMERGENCY
BY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THERE
IS NO PROVISION IN THE ACT TO
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE
OVERSIGHT. OF EXECUTIVE
DECISIONS MADE DURING MARTIN C.
THIS BILL IS NOT INTENDED TO
LIVE THE GOVERNOR THIRTY TO
SWIFTLY RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES
OR PURSUE FEDERAL DISASTER
ASSISTANCE. BUT RATHER TO
INCREASE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
OF EXECUTIVE ACTIONS AND
SPENDING MADE DURING THOSE
EMERGENCIES. PERSPECTIVES FROM
A VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
RODRIGUEZ DO WE HAVE ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NONE OKAY AND DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM.
NOT I'M GONNA DO WHAT I'M GONNA
DO IS GO ONTO THEIR PRIMARY
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYBODY IN
PRIMARY OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
AND THERE ARE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES FOR THAT ON THE ASK
FOR ANY OPPOSING OUR OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM. THERE
ARE NONE WE'RE GOING TO OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME. WHETHER YOU ARE YOU THE
ORGANIZATION REPRESENT AND ALSO
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
AND THAT'S ALL. SO IF THE
OPERATOR CAN OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES. MODERATOR AND LIKE
MILLION GERMAN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
ELEVEN TWENTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN ONE ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NONE IN OUR
QUEUE- PLEASE CONTINUE MISTER
CHAIR THERE BEING NOBODY ON THE
LINES AND WE'RE GOING TO BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS WE ALREADY HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. MR
GALLAGHER GO AHEAD YEAH I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN FOR BRING
FOR THIS BILL BUT I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT- I THINK AS WE
SAW VERY CLEAR LAST YEAR
THERE'S A MUCH GREATER NEED FOR
TRANSPARENCY- ON SPENDING
DECISIONS ON YOU KNOW HOW
THINGS ARE BEING HOW DECISIONS
ARE GETTING MADE THAT AFFECT
ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS AND-
ALL TOO OFTEN LAST YEAR WE WERE
NOT GETTING THE ANSWERS THAT WE
NEEDED- AND- SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE THIS.
FOURTEEN COMING BACK TO US. I
ALSO THINK THAT WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT EMERGENCY
SERVICES ACT AND ENSURE THAT WE
RETAIN GREATER CONTROLS- YOU
KNOW OVER THE GOVERNOR'S
EMERGENCY POWERS- AND THAT
YOU'LL TO MADE AS THE PEOPLE'S
REPRESENTATIVES- THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO ENSURE THE PROPER
CHECKS AND BALANCES AND SO ON I
MEAN I KNOW MYSELF AND OTHERS
HAVE MEASURES TO. YOU KNOW SORT
OF. RIGHT IN THE GAMUT FROM YOU
KNOW LIMITING THE TIME FRAME
FOR AN EMERGENCY- YOU KNOW TO
OTHER REFORMS THAT WOULD HAVE
NOTICED BETTER ENSURE THOSE
CHECKS AND BALANCES SO I HOPE
THAT WILL BE- IN THOSE BILL
SHORTLY AS WELL- AND I THINK
THAT THE COMBINATION OF HAVING
BOTH. GREATER INFORMATION
TRANSPARENCY AND REFORMS. YOU
KNOW TO THAT EMERGENCY SERVICES
ACTIVE THINKER ARE VERY MUCH
WANTED SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY AND THANK THE
CHAIR FOR. BRINGING THIS
MEASURE. THE COMMENTS FROM
OTHER MEMBERS. AND I'LL JUST OF
THERE ARE NONE NOW OFFER A
QUICK COMMENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER HAS
POINTED OUT- YOU KNOW THE
EMERGENCY CENTRALIZING YOUR
DECISION MAKING IN THE
EMERGENCY AND THE EARLY STAGE
OF EMERGENCY IS REALLY
IMPORTANT- BUT- THERE ARE
CHECKS AND BALANCES BURKE BELT
IN ANY ORGANIZATION INCLUDING.
THE GREAT STATE OF THE CAL OF
CALIFORNIA. AND YOU KNOW THIS
IS IMPORTANT WE CANNOT AS A
LEGISLATURE SIMPLY ABDICATE OUR
ROLE- LONG TERM- IN AN
EMERGENCY. THERE ARE THINGS
THAT ARE APPROPRIATELY MADE
DECISIONS ARE PROPELLING IT
MADE AN EMERGENCY- IN A
CENTRALIZED MANNER BUT THERE
ARE OTHER THINGS THAT. ARE NOT
NECESSARY FOR THAT. AND IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO- CONTINUE
TO HAVE THOSE CHECKS AND
BALANCES THAT WE NEED THAT ARE
CALIFORNIANS RESIDENTS DEPEND
ON- I THINK- WE NEED TO ADDRESS
IT AND I THINK YOUR BILL GOES A
LONG WAYS THEY'RE DOING THAT. I
THINK THERE OTHERS SOME OTHER
THINGS THAT CONGRESS IS DONE
THAT MAYBE WE CAN LOOK AT. AND
HOPEFULLY WILL CONTINUE
EXPLORING THIS- BUT WITH THAT-
I RECOMMEND OUR DAY. YOU KNOW
WE RECOMMEND AND I BOTH. THANK
YOU. MA'AM YOU CAN ARE AT THE
GO AHEAD AND CLOSE I'M SORRY MR
SPECTRUM RIGHT OKAY THANK OU.
I'M SECRETARY GO AHEAD AND CALL
THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SAT DOWN HI UP AYE
AYE GREGORY. AYE GREGORY AYE
CALDERON. CALDERON I GALLAGHER.
FIVE GALLAGHER I OKAY. GREAT
WERE. FORD HI THE SIX FOOT
THREE THAT BILLS OUT TO YOU
VERY MUCH. THE CHAIR. YEAH.
YEAH WITHOUT OBJECTION. THE
ROLE. SO THAT I KNOW WE STILL
HAVE A COUPLE MISSION MEMBERS
ON A COUPLE VOTE SO WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND OF THE ROLE OPEN FOR
A FEW MORE MINUTES- MARKET
START THEM NOW I THINK. WITHOUT
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SECRETARY
CALL THE MISSING MEMBERS.
CALDERON CALDERON HI GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER I AGREE GREAT ABSENT.
OKAY WITH THAT THE SCORN TO
FILE ITEM ISSUE- NUMBERS OF
FILE NUMBER ONE AB ELEVEN
HUNDRED CURRY SECRETARY CALL
THE MISSING MEMBERS GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOW GRAY OKAY ABSENT.
OKAY FROM NUMBER TWO. A. B.
ELEVEN OH THREE A SECRETARY
CALLED THE MISSING MEMBERS OKAY-
ABSENT. WHAT TELEPHONE NUMBER
THREE AB FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN
COOLEY ALL MEMBERS WERE PRESENT
FORMER PRESIDENT. AND I KNOW WE
STILL HAVE- THE COMMISSION
MARIE ADAM GRAY I THINK WE'RE
JUST OLDER OR OPEN FOR ANOTHER
FIVE MINUTES. THANK YOU FOR. IT
WAS WORTH ABOUT TWENTY. I
DETECT THAT BASICALLY ON.
LARGEST WHAT IF YOU MISS THE
MISSILE. ALL RIGHT SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL FOR CONSENT
CALENDAR CALLED MISSION MEMBERS.
I WITH THE FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB ELEVEN HUNDRED GRAD
SECRETARY MISSING MEMBERS OKAY
FIVE OKAY I. HAVE A FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO A. B. ELEVEN OH
THREE. ALL THE MISSING NUMBERS.
IS A MAKING DAILY. I. THE OTHER
ONES YOU THIS DISTRICT AND THEN
PHONE NUMBER FOR A. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY THREE RODRIGUEZ OKAY
CONSUMERS. A LOT OF THINGS AND
I THINK WITH THE SIGNATURE I
THINK WE HAVE ALL OF AMONG
COMPLETED. RIGHT WITH THAT. I
BELIEVE THIS MAKE IT IS A
JOURNEY WE HAVE ALL ITEMS-
VOTED AND EVERYTHING IS OUT I
THANK YOUR MAJESTY JR THANKS.